[Applause]
dear prime minister
justin trudeau
the deputy prime minister christian
freeland
the minister of foreign affairs melanie
jolie
here ambassador
ambassador to leon
code
here ambassador hoskin
here mrs donselman of allianz who has
made it possible for us to host this
event
at the airlines forum at the brandenburg
gates thank you very much for
giving us the opportunity to meet here
in this building
esteemed members of the diplomatic corps
distinguished guests
canada and germany
are closely linked of course
in nato in which canada together
with all other allies protected the
freedom of west berlin
and west germany for decades
and together with others made
the peaceful reunification of our
country possible
it's a special honor for atlantic
brooker
and unit security conference to welcome
you
here justin trudeau
is our best guest of honor today to talk
about the situation in europe
atlantic worker turned 70 this year
and we are pleased that the pillars
of that bridge are built on a firm and
stable foundation
on both sides of the atlantic and i'm
especially proud that on this occasion i
can announce
that we have a founding of an atlantic
canada
as an independent
sister organization
ladies and gentlemen hardly any other
country is as closely linked to the
european ideas
of the enlightenment and its ideas of
freedom
democracy and human rights as canada is
and occasionally i thought sometimes
canada
is more european than some of our
european member states
therefore please allow me just
because my former colleague christian
freeland
is among us it would be a good signal
just now
if after more than five years
the german bundestag would finally
rectify
the free trade agreement sita
which not only brings advantages for
both sides
but above all is the most modern free
trade agreement of our time
because right now we are realizing
we are living in a time in which even
fundamental foundations
of peaceful coexistence between
peoples do not endure
war is once again
raging in the middle of europe for the
first time since 1939 when my country
started the second world war a war of
aggression
is being waged on europe soil again
almost 80 years
after the inhuman nazi regime was
defeated
and 30 years after the end of the cold
war
putin's war of aggression makes clear
that we are entering again
new dark ages
no other buildings represent this
difficult water history of europe and
germany
better than the great blockade when we
just went through
throughout the cold war it was the
symbol
of a world divided
a world in which two are geological
blocks stood face to face
threatening mutually assured destruction
with nuclear weapons
but it also stands for the ability to
overcome the dark ages
it was before the grendenberg gate where
u.s president ronald reagan famously
demanded
tear down this wall mr gorbachev
in 1990 when the soviet union collapsed
and the iron curtain fell
rattenberg cape became a symbol for
peace
and freedom in europe
today germany stands firm as a
democratic
liberal country in the transatlantic
community of elders
200 years after its construction it
seemed that red brickgate
finally would deserve the name that was
originally
intended for it
peacegate
but we also that even in europe war is
possible again even though russia had
moved well over 150 000 troops to
ukraine's border
since last year
until 10 days ago
we did not want to believe that vladimir
putin would
dare to invade
its neighbor
or that wars of aggression could return
to europe
russia's president's war of aggression
is not about ukraine
but about reconstituting this country as
a great power especially in europe
he wants to determine the future and
faith of europe again
and it's not the old soviet union that
serves as his model for this
but
zarest russia
russia's president
thinks that the categories of the 18th
and 19th century
wages a war for the means of the 20th
century and believes that he can
determine the 21st century with it
the conflict with russia is not about a
war of the west
against russia
as russian propaganda likes to publicly
publicly proclaim
russia is waging a war against all
fundamental norms
of international law
if the world community allowed this to
happen here in europe
it would be a dangerous lesson for other
properties in the
world for this reason
we are grateful for all those who
condemn this war of aggression
and use their opportunities to stand by
ukraine
and increase the pressure on russia's
president
to finally stop his war of aggression
war is horrible
we feel for the worst innocent victims
and admire the brave
and courageous ukrainians standing
firmly against the aggression
but we also feel for those in russia and
belarus that oppose this war
and their authocratic regimes but who
cannot express their opinion without
having to fear for their freedom and
their life
but we must not lose faith in ourselves
and the ability of our liberal
and free societies to withstand the
anachronism of war and autocracy
there is a future
this is precisely why in this dawning
21st century
the trans-atlantic partnership is taking
on a new significance
we have shown before that the peace gate
can be built
if we stand together and never give up
or believe that a better world is
possible
we can overcome the darkness of war
and conflict again
what is clear however is that europe and
its member states especially germany
must assume a greater role in
maintaining europe's security and peace
i am glad that my government has now
taken both steps in this direction
and shown its resolve to address the
tectonic geopolitical shifts
stretching beyond europe and the euro
atlantic that we are witnessing
at the dawn of the 21st century
and i'm sure your prime minister
minister trudeau he will give us now
important guidance
on how we can further strengthen the
transatlantic community
and work together to secure
freedom
peace and prosperity in all parts of
europe thank you very much for coming
and for your commitment
[Applause]
thank you sigmar
for that warm introduction it's so great
to see you again we
really did work very well together
during the season negotiations and
you've always been a friend and an ally
to canada and to democracies around the
world
i'm looking forward to my conversation
with anna and with all of you
i want to thank atlantic
for the ending munich security
confidence for bringing us together
it's a real honor for me to address you
today
it's also very good to see ambassador
hoisin today christopher i will always
remember that during your final closing
speech at the u.n security council
you chose to take part of your time
to call once again for the freedom of
michael coverage and michael spavor two
canadians who were arbitrarily detained
in china
thanks in part to your advocacy and the
advocacy of friends and allies around
the world those two men are at home now
thank you
when i was preparing my notes for
today's events
i remember
speaking in 2017 at the saint matthews
day banquet hosted by
then-mayor of hamburg hola
sigmar was there too
he actually delivered remarks right
before me that night too
the world has changed in the intervening
five years
what i said then remains true today
canada and germany
have long been partners on the world
stage because we share a progressive
vision of the world we understand the
importance of international cooperation
and partnership
we value
the rule of law
and democracy
it's great to be back in berlin today
of all places the people of berlin
know what it is
to fight for democracy
i don't have to tell you how much work
it takes
because you already understand that
democracy never happens
by accident
and as we're reminded now
it certainly doesn't continue
without effort
when vladimir putin launched a
full-scale invasion of ukraine
he violated russia's international
treaties and he attacked the values that
form the pillars of all democracies
this kind of brazen disregard for law
and human life
is a massive threat to europe
and to the world
foreign
[Music]
foreign president zalensky and ukrainian
people who are demonstrating so much
courage
and resilience
they're not only defending their country
they're defending the democratic values
that are so important to all of us
they're standing up to authoritarianism
canada and germany
stand with them
with our allies and partners we've put
in place
the toughest sanctions ever imposed on a
major economy
we're making sure putin
is held accountable for his actions
canada also remains unwavering in our
support for nato
we're supporting nato's efforts to
protect euro-atlantic security
democracy
and the rules-based international system
we worked so hard to build together
last month
chancellor schultz made a historic
announcement to shift german policy
to meet the challenges of today
including by supporting ukraine with
legal aid and military equipment
while canada and germany have stepped up
to help defend ukraine
so has all of europe
under the leadership of president funda
a proud european and a proud german
the european union is mobilized to
defend democracy
and in this germany the european union
can count on the full
support of canada
vladimir putin is undoubtedly a threat
to ukrainians
and a threat to people beyond their
borders
but even as we are clear-eyed about the
challenge he represents
we mustn't despair
because at its best
democracy
is always
stronger than authoritarianism
but if we're going to be honest with
each other
democracy hasn't exactly been at its
best
these past few years
even as we're fighting putin's invasion
we need to recommit ourselves
to the work of strengthening our
democracies
apathy
cynicism
misinformation and disinformation
declining voter turnout
mistrust in our institutions
it's our job
to rebuild
that trust
to give people reasons to have faith
in our institutions
to get involved
in civic life
we can't let
fear anxiety
and envy
overcome the hope
the
earnest
optimism
that is
necessary
for democracies to thrive
we can't settle for simplistic answers
to complex problems
we can't let nativism
distract from the hard work of
building better systems and real
solutions
these challenges are not easy for any of
us
but addressing them head-on
and
[Music]
we all
have a responsibility to deal in facts
into flight to fight the flood of
disinformation and manipulation
while social media has a profound
positive effect on society it also has a
role in enabling harmful content like
hate speech and misinformation
domestically our government is working
on a new new legislation to address
online harms
this year
canada is chair of the freedom online
coalition
and our goal is to encourage the public
to have informed and meaningful
engagement in society both offline and
online
we all have more work to do
in the 1930s
thomas mann
described how democracy is built on the
respect
for the infinite dignity
of each individual
one of the most powerful ideas canada
hopes to share with the world is
our deep and abiding belief in diversity
not only do we believe in it
we embrace it
although that's not to say we have it
all figured out
we're making progress
but there's always more work to be done
on fighting systemic racism
on gender equality
on defending lgbtq2 communities
on reconciliation
indigenous peoples
last summer
mary simon became
the first indigenous governor general in
canada's history
when she was in germany for her first
state visit just a few months ago
she led canada's delegation
at the frankfurt book fair
because it's only through sharing
knowledge
and listening
to indigenous people's perspectives
that we can hope to fully achieve
reconciliation
that's why we need
to stay open to hearing their truths and
honoring their stories through books
oral history and celebrating together
their culture
the respect
for the infinite dignity of each
individual
means no one
should get left out
this is also true
for people who hold different political
views
we all need to commit
to more listening
and less shouting
diversity of ideas
helps us learn from one another
talking with people who think
differently from us
is how we challenge ourselves
challenging ourselves is how we grow
so by strengthening our open inclusive
societies
everyone benefits
democracy benefits
it is true for canada
it is true for germany
and it's true for everyone around the
world
whether it's
the immediate challenge of high gas
prices
or the long-term consequences of climate
change
democracies
need to be at their best
to have the tough conversations needed
to figure that out
earlier today
germany signed on to canada's global
carbon pricing challenge and canada
signed on to germany's climate
club now not only do we both have a
price on pollution at home we will both
be driving this work on the world stage
too
canada and germany are
also two of the world's biggest
economies
so when we stand united on something
it matters
after all as this crisis in ukraine has
laid bare
we must keep working together
i know that european leaders have been
calling for acceleration and the shift
to clean sustainable power as putin
tries to hold a continent of homes
hostage
over oil and gas
so i want to commend
the leadership of chancellor schultz to
halt
the certification of nordstrom 2 russian
pipeline
this was not an easy decision but it was
the right decision
you will not bend
to intimidation and you will find a path
forward on a secure and sustainable
energy future you've made your vision
clear
and canada will stand with you
my friends
as long as we don't take our democracy
for granted
as long as we keep working to make it
better
as long as we stay united
we needn't ever feel intimidated by
tyrants
over the past years
putin made the mistake of seeing
disagreements
as division
and debates
as weakness
it's actually our greatest strength
this friday
will mark two years since the world
health organization declared covet 19 a
pandemic
this health crisis has been a challenge
unlike any other
but it also showed
how people stepped up
for one another
everyone rolled up their sleeves
and worked together
that
is the story of the pandemic
we worked together
just like we're seeing now from people
all around the world offering to welcome
ukrainian refugees
and send humanitarian aid
putin
made serious miscalculations
he underestimated the incredible courage
of the ukrainian people
and he underestimated the resolve and
unity
of democratic allies and partners
in the face of authoritarianism
we have to continue fighting lies with
truth
fear with facts
division
with unity
as you all know
the atlantic
turns 70 years old this year
i can tell you that this bridge of
transatlantic cooperation between our
nations will remain strong and sturdy
for many years to come
like i said
a lot has changed since i was in humber
five years ago
however
the importance of working together to
allow democracy to flourish and
ultimately to prevail
is as true today
as it was then
democracy
is not just a concept
in a political science textbook
it's our everyday lives
standing up for our shared values
requires
constant efforts
but i know that canadians
germans and people everywhere are up to
the challenge
in the words of president zielenski
light
will win over darkness
[Applause]